joining us is dr celine gallander who
recently was appointed to
president-elect biden's covid19 advisory
board
she is an epidemiologist and infectious
disease expert at the nyu grossman
school of medicine and bellevue hospital
right here in new york dr gaunder thank
you so much for joining us
it's great to be here you know it's no
secret millions of people have traveled
this week
despite those warnings from health
officials to stay home what do you
expect
to see in the coming days and weeks as a
result
well we can fully anticipate that we are
going to see cases rising
on top of this current surge in the next
couple weeks
i'm really worried that come christmas
and new year's
we're really going to be struggling to
have people in the icus
finding a bed for them in the icus and i
think
unfortunately you have health care
workers who are already exhausted from
months of fighting this
they themselves need a break over the
holidays
and you know i think many of us are just
really really
worried about what this is going to look
like today is black friday of course and
you know that people love to shop they
love to shop online but is that
something that you're actually
encouraging more people to do
uh to avoid those crowds and the
possibility of exposure to cover 19.
well look drink our advice on this
remains the same whether it's with
respect to shopping or hanging out with
family or whatever it is you need to be
masking you need to be social distancing
so
remaining six feet apart from other
people who are not inside your household
bubble
trying to be in the best ventilated
spaces possible if you are around other
people so that means
ideally outdoors or if not outdoors with
doors and
whip it windows open quite wide so going
to a mall and shopping in crowds is
really not
on the list of things that would be safe
right now is that something though that
the biden administration would be
advising
people to stay home and shop online
knowing how many people
generally go out during this time
i think our advice would be to stay away
from crowds whether that's for
shopping or for rallies or for
music concerts whatever it is you know
really i think staying away from crowds
is really sound advice right now
speaking of which you know the supreme
court recently blocked covid 19 limits
on churches
do you think that that is a good thing a
bad thing obviously you all
are maintaining that people need to stay
home and not in crowds but this allows
people to gather
without those restrictions in new york
well look i'm not a lawyer i can only
speak to the public health implications
of this i do think we
have seen that churches synagogues and
other places of worship have been sites
of transmission
there are ways to practice safely to
practice your religion
safely some uh houses of worship have
moved their services online others have
done so
outside so you know i don't think it
should have to be
either your religion and your religious
freedom versus public health i think
there are ways
we can do both you also say you don't
like the word lockdown but in
cases if cases rather continue to rise
how would you advise president-elect
biden
get things under control
yeah i think we've said repeatedly um
and as has the president-elect and the
vice president-elect that we are not
entertaining another lockdown or
shutdown uh
the way i think about this is in the
spring we had
a on and off light switch which was the
shutdown lockdown approach and now that
we understand the transmission better
that we understand that this is
predominantly a droplet an aerosol
spread virus respiratory virus not so
much contact
and we also have a better understanding
of who transmits and where
we can be a lot more specific in our
restrictions so we've moved from that
on and off light switch to a dimmer
switch where we can dial up and dial
down restrictions
we can do so in a geographically
targeted way
and so we can restrict yes but in a way
that's less burdensome on
on the average person dr celine
gallander thank you so much for joining
us happy holidays
you too